imaginez 25 ans deuxième présentation à
cannes celle là dépasse la première bien
trois ans présentation du film home y en
a beaucoup parlé douze ou treize minutes
d'ovation hier soir on sera demain au
début d'après midi heure de montréal ici
xavier dolan recevra ou non la palme
d'or mais déjà deux c'est un parcours
exceptionnel
j'ai rejoint à quelques minutes ma
collègue tanya lapointe qui est toujours
à cannes
tanya lapointe quand on s'est laissé
hier un peu après on a vu ces images de
xavier dolan qui pleurait ému bien sûr
de cette réaction dans la grande salle
du festival à cannes j'imagine qu'il n'a
pas dû dormir beaucoup cette nuit il lui
est encore sur un nuage
ou est fort probablement il y avait une
fête qui était organisée évidemment peau
souligné le triomphe de momies en
première mondiale et ce matin au réveil
à plusieurs des journaux parler de lui
en une libération lui offrait la moitié
de ça promet de sa première page donc
beaucoup d'attention beaucoup de
curiosité entourant et xavier dolan qui
était également invitée avec toute cette
distribution sur le plateau du grand
journal de canal+ dont qui est un des
diffuseurs principaux du festival que
beaucoup de place ici à cannes au cours
des dernières semaines alors ben voilà
xavier dolan qu'on s'arrache qui pique
la curiosité les gens nous arrêtent
lorsqu'ils entendent l'accent de chez
nous pour nous dire qu'ils ont vu et
xavier de le film de xavier dolan demi
et qu'il souhaite que le film remporte
la palme d'or donc et on peut réellement
parler d'un engouement ici à calme oui
le grand journal nous en parler c'est
intéressant parce que l'animateur lui
demande demandé afin de le remercier en
disant vous nous avez donné du vrai
cinéma enfin du vrai cinéma la glisse en
tant que si le coup de coeur mais est-ce
que ce coup de coeur va automatiquement
tania se transformer en palme d'or la
fois être prudent car oui il faut être
très prudent parce qu'évidemment c'est
le jury qui décide ce ne sont pas les
critiques ce n'est pas le public non
plus un jour qui restent à l'écart de
tout ce qui se passe tu ne lis pas les
critiques et qui pourrait prendre des
décisions qui pourraient nous surprendre
cela dit xavier dolan pourrait obtenir
la palme d'or si le jury a qui est
présidée par jane campion misé sur la
jeunesse ce que souhaite en fait et
xavier dolan il l'a souvent dit hier en
conférence de presse donc ici ne gagne
pas la palme d'or il pourrait quand même
repartir avec un des nombreux prix alors
il y a en plus de la palme d'or il y a
le grand prix qui est l'équivalent de la
médaille d'argent du festival de cannes
il y a le prix du jury qui est
l'équivalent du de la médaille de bronze
et ensuite il y a le prix de la
meilleure mise en scène qu'on appelle
chez nous la meilleure réalisation
meilleur scénario meilleur acteur
meilleure actrice alors plusieurs prises
sept en tout que pourrait obtenir momie
mais sachez que contrairement aux oscars
un film ne peut pas remporter plusieurs
prix un prix par film c'est tout et donc
c'est là le défi du jury de déterminer
qu'est-ce qu'on privilégie est ce que le
jeu par exemple dans dorval doit être
récompensé davantage que la réalisation
de xavier dolan ou si le film au complet
qui doit recevoir la palme d'or alors ce
sera tout un défi pour le jury et bref y
aura sûrement des surprises mais chose
certaine avec l'engouement entourant ce
film m'a mis un risque fort de se
retrouver au palmarès on le répète ne
serait-ce que ce qu'on entend dans
l'industrie du cinéma ici très bien
c'est demain notre heure c'est demain
après midi début d'après midi samedi
qu'on sera tous chat par ailleurs damien
avant de vous laisser il ya d'autres
films d'autres films canadiens à
d'autres films - dans ce grand festival
oui on a aussi beaucoup parlé des trois
réalisateurs canadiens en compétition
officielle c'est une première historique
cela dit le film d'atom egoyan captive
ne risque pas de se retrouver au
palmarès est le film qui a été le plus
mal reçus pendant toute la compétition
maps taux de stress de david cronenberg
a eu reçu une critique beaucoup plus
positive il ya peut-être jour yann moix
qui pourrait se retrouver avec une
récompense dans la catégorie meilleure
interprète féminine et il y avait aussi
stéphane lafleur avec son film tu dors
nicole qui était présenté à la quinzaine
des réalisateurs la cérémonie clôture
avait lieu ce soir mais c'est plutôt le
film le combattant qui est repartie
grands gagnants mais tout de même une
présence marquée pour tu dors nichols a
obtenu un accueil plutôt chaleureux ici
à cannes alors voir atteignent un bon
festival bonne fin de festival à vous on
se croise les doigts demain pour xavier
dolan qui deviendrait corrigez moi si je
me trompe d'un lien le plus jeune
réalisateur de fiction à recevoir la
palme d'or à cannes ce n'est pas rien
c'est exact c'est exact alors on lui
souhaite aussi et ce soir on va aller
voir si guy laliberté n'est pas à cannes
pour un événement bénéfice pour sa
fondation one drop ici les journées sont
longues et on en profite jusqu'au bout
merci tania salut